oui il fait beau et chaud bon va pas
parler de la météo tu as vu là ils ont
dit qu'ils allaient remettre le service
militaire a cité un extrait sur internet
n'importe quoi aujourd'hui on fait la
guerre avec des drones et des robots ça
va ils ont plus besoin de nous en tout
cas c'est sûr ils n'ont pas besoin de
moi oui l'idée c'est de renforcer
l'union nationale le patriotisme pas à
la coupe du monde c'est tous les quatre
ans donc faut bien deux premiers trucs
en attendant fin mais le problème c'est
qu'apparemment ce sera aussi pour les
filles et ceux rendus compte qu'en fait
nous aussi on savait faire des pompes et
découvrir dans la boue je t'avais dit
christine 1 que tout ce truc sur
l'égalité ça vous retomberait sur la
gueule j'avais du retard et m'a dit tu
vas voiture m'écouter en tout cas
j'espère que ce sera mixte non parce que
moi je peux pas me permettre de perdre
encore un an pour trouver un mec pas ça
fait 35 ans quand même un déjà est long
après quand je vois les gens qui font du
crossfit en bas de chez moi je me dis
que le service militaire il n'a jamais
vraiment disparu livia à 7h du mat il
porte des fois en courant à travers les
voitures et le pire c'est que personne
les zones et nous a light ont pourri son
cousin questions qui te disent dans la
banque mais bon on n'a rien fait pendant
à et puis moi je déteste qu'on me donne
des ordres et que dans un jeu de rôles
sexuels que tu m'entendras dire oui chef
tu deguisetoi à tous non mais on dormait
l'oin pour canet quoi ce qui est cool
c'est que tu peux passer ton ferme et
gratuitement pendant ton service au mois
qui galère c'est top après moi c'est pas
le côté payant qui me pose problème
c'est plus le côté conduite bien que je
galère à faire un créneau avec une
twingo alors avec un ton qui avait fait
valoir partout drouot florence or s'ils
vont pas céder celle fille de jet ski à
dubaï aux photos de la caserne de
beauvais
elle a bien fait pour leur gueule
mais entre nous christine remettre le
service militaire d'accord mais va
peut-être aussi penser à remettre la
guerre histoire que ça sur la cage de
chose toi faut réfléchir jusqu'au bout
lewiston couillon
mais quand même c'est un état
totalitaire ou quoi enfermer les gens
comme ça a atteint la jeune star ils
disent que c'est que pour les 18 20 ans
bon bah après c'est pas une si mauvaise
idée hein ça va les remettre dans leurs
attaques je te rappelle c'est ma pizza
ouais bisous
bonjour
tami oui c'est pour vous bon appétit au
revoir
[Musique]